[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
renverser le capitalisme et le remplacer
par un régime de propriété collective
nous en avons souvent parlé je restais
mois avant 1914 la république par une
succession de réformes étalé dans le
temps
conduire est tout naturellement à la
démocratie socialiste
mais aujourd'hui la donne a changé
jaurès est mort et nous sortons de
l'effroyable boucherie ces quatre années
de guerre mondiale ont tué l'espérance
dans la force en russie les mines et des
siens renverser l'ordre établi
ils promettent aux prolétaires du monde
entier des lendemains radieux beaucoup
en france veulent emprunter ce chemin
dans notre parti socialiste une majorité
se dessine en ce sens tout à l'heure à
tour
notre parti se réunira en congrès je
suis minoritaire
je montrais la tribu s'il vous plaît
à part les tours plus encore de la
minorité camarades cloud
[Musique]
chaque marin que ne ferait pas pour
l'adhésion à la troisième internationale
même si cette position est aujourd'hui
majoritaire
le communisme c'est la subordination
absolue au chef la coexistence
d'organismes officiels et d'appareils
clandestins c'est donc dans les faits le
pouvoir réel
un comité en culte bascou exige
l'abandon dans tout ce que nous sommes
depuis jaurès est ce là deux parties que
nous avons connue non telle partie bloom
un parti vendu à la bourgeoisie de
partie des ouvriers camarades de la
démocratie de la république
l'appel aux masses et pas cette petite
avant-garde discipliné putschistes que
moscou participation au gouvernement
guerre des oubliés chers camarades
l'union sacrée c'était la défense de la
patrie contre l'agression allemande qui
s'en réclament aujourd'hui en temps de
paix et le camarade cachin qui est des
vôtres a lui aussi participé à l'union
sacrée que tu me reproches choix
et
parlons clair la volonté de lénine
cette conquête du pouvoir par la force
comme en 1917
son objectif c'est la révolution
mondiale par la violence je suis moi
aussi partisans de la dictature du
prolétariat mais cela ne signifie pas
que je renonce au combat pour la
démocratie et les libertés
au contraire
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu aurais a parlé en 1920
personne ne connaissait thorez je me
demande même s'il était délégué cache un
oui cachette est assis là là beaucoup ne
regarder que lui il rentrait de moscou
il avait vu lénine
vous regrettez rien de votre discours 16
ans après
pourquoi revenir ici et remuer tout ça
monsieur bouchard je suis historien
monsieur blum ce que mon travail pendant
que vous irez courir laventure il faut
que quelqu'un reste gardé la vieille
maison malgré tout restons les frères
part à séparer une querelle de famille
et qu'un foyer commun pourra encore
réunir
j'avais raison pardon oui j'avais raison
une internationale militariser la
dictature la fin des libertés
on voit où cela a conduit les
bolchéviques avait tort si socialistes
n'est pas la liberté alors à quoi bon
croyez vous que ces photos soient
indispensables à votre livre monsieur
bouchard par les mois plus tôt du canada
je connais un peu les états unis mais le
canada je suis québécois de québec c'est
un peu de france au milieu du continent
américain
mais les français l'ont oublié
bonjour a lieu à 12
[Musique]
ce matin mon 142 gare d'austerlitz pour
le parti dit oui oui c'est bruyant je
suis dans un café il ya treize jeunes
tu me manques je t'embrasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malraux me harcèle pour que j'aille à
luz où c'est intéressant dre mais
attention les eaux et moi sommes dues
aux voyageurs
toi tu rentres de tours et moi je
m'apprête à partir pour moscou
c'est vrai qu'il ya un lien entre ces
deux villes précise sa pensée
j'étais dans la salle du congrès 16 ans
après comme si c'était hier
et pourtant si loin comme le temps
galope et puis il y avait ce professeur
n'a pas quitté une minute
un universitaire canadien il écrit un
livre sur lyon j'imagine tout
enthousiasme et bien mes amis je bois à
vous chers gide
vous devriez diffusé à la presse la
photo de cette coupe ébréchée ou croatie
riches cela ne marcherait pas on dirait
que le juive l'oma truqués la photo et
non plus tôt ce qui agite la république
des lettres
mon journal l'hebdomadaire des
intellectuels pour le front populaire
comme autant de la fois dreyfus ont
chargé de vous gâcher votre talent à
ferrailler contre l'action française
morasse a le style ouais c'est sympa un
article 101 appel aux martres oui mais
votre front populaire va faire augmenter
les charges de nos entreprises comme si
nous pouvions de payer ce luxe ont
toujours le même refrain
le patronat ne changera jamais les
usines ferment les travailleurs sont
licenciés les familles réduites à la
misère mais moi sur thérèse oublier que
la crise économique est mondiale
je n'oublie rien niveau profit ni
l'arrogance des vôtres lambert ibo grèce
ce n'est pas l'homme du patronat qui
permit de ce soir c'est mon ami et
collègue du conseil d'état la cedr
accueille orléans
l'alliance avec les communistes ne
t'inquiète pas tous eu pas naïfs
alexandre rien à craindre du pc staline
a trop peur que l'europe fascistes se
retourne contre lui
voilà enfin une bonne nouvelle j'ai
besoin des communistes ils influencent
les masses sans compter les
intellectuels enfin les ont tout de même
le le plus est avec toi c'est le loup
dans la bergerie
j'ai peut-être t'étonner mais quand nous
avons négocié le programme du front
populaire
thorez était le plus modéré n'assistait
même pas qu'on se limite à quelques
mesures sociales pour rassurer les
radicaux
on était loin de la dictature du
prolétariat
je m'en souviens c'était même assis à ma
droite donc c'est toi qui est la nature
les nationalisations les hausses de
salaires et le droit syndical
ah oui c'était bien loin
décidément je ne comprendrais jamais
arrivé à la politique
thérèse cesse d'agresser lambert ibo tue
la vie de swat mais il ne me demande pas
de mettre mon drapeau dans ma poche
d'ailleurs je me trouve encore trop
modéré je suis bi ton influence
je ne demande qu'à peu de courtoisie je
trouve que tu est parfois trop
conciliant conciliant parce que l'homme
du patronat est mon ami tout à l'heure
quand lambert i bought a demandé de
modérer les camarades du parti qu'est ce
que tu lui ai répondu tu as dit j'ai 63
ans semblent au prochain congrès je
passerai la main je suis trop vieux pour
me lancer dans de nouveaux combats
je trouve ça drôle d'être mariée à un
homme qui veut passer la main
[Musique]
à vous
je peux le dire monsieur bouchard je les
ai rencontrés quand j'avais 20 ans
j'étais mariée
j'ai très vite deviné ses sentiments
mais je savais qu'il ne quitterait
jamais sa femme lise qui était malade
d'alors
je me suis éloigné et vous a poursuivi
les portes et souvent cure
il restait seul sous le travail le parti
ses livres ses articles pas une minute à
lui
et puis il y avait jean jaurès
c'était une fascination réciproque
jaurès exigeait beaucoup de lui donc
[Musique]
vous vous êtes perdus de vue non
non
un soir on s'est croisés sur les
boulevards et sortait d'un théâtre
moi d'une réunion de section
c'était en avril 1911
conservez on s'est écrit sa femme le
savait
dans les premiers jours de la guerre
elle a trouvé une autre
elle a accepté
en
après sa mort en 1931 nous sommes mariés
tout cela est bien utile pour une
biographie mathieu bouchard précisément
écrire une biographie c'est d'abord
comprendre un art mais léon blum est
étrange
il prend l'union libre qui se marient
deux fois écoutez ce qui dit il m'a
fallu quelques courage pour dominer le
préjugé favorable que l'union libre
m'inspirait car l'homme et la femme sont
d'abord polygame
l'homme est plein de contradictions mais
aussi aux bouchard et malgré tout vous
avez dit oui oui vous n'aviez pas peur
de son penchant pour la polygamie
non je suis irrésistible
[Musique]
salut j'ai encore beaucoup d'ouvriers et
sefyu autant qu'aux pc mais dans notre
section sud plutôt des employés des
fonctionnaires des cheminots quelques
femmes elles surtout ils étendent de
choc
le professeur bouchard qui écrit un
livre sur les manifs m'ont ému enchanté
de faire votre connaissance mademoiselle
excusez moi mais nous avons un drôle
d'accent les québécois
parfait
[Musique]
de g
du tout
ça
enfin
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais abordé des élections avec
autant d'incertitudes
il faut que la campagne électorale soit
vraiment unitaire daladier des radicaux
diront oui j'ai confiance
reste à convaincre torres le centre le
difficile si elle ne suffira pas aller
au bout ne gagnera pas ces élections
c'est passé lui il faut se mobiliser un
mauvais résultat est la droite pactisent
avec les fascistes faut se battre
tu as raison mais on ne gagnera pas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
et ce sont les camelots du roi
les enterre bainville
en mal on ne peut pas faire deux mi
temps mathieu blom c'est blum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
capture de la veine temporal hémorragie
contusions multiples c'est donc une
chance de se mouiller choc a été violent
madame
mes lunettes
ne t'inquiète pas je te ramène une paire
quand pourra-t-il sortir docteur numéro
de madame je file à la mévente chercher
des affaires repose tâche et madame une
délégation du parti vient d'arriver vous
senti dans le hall
non
les sauver enfin presque
voilà des mois que je vous mets en garde
la presse déchaînée les appels au
meurtre je vous demandais des
garde-corps rien ils ont failli le tuer
maintenant laissez le tranquille je vous
dirai quand vous pourrez le voir elle
est plutôt rassuré les camarades et
organiser la riposte
[Musique]
les hommes cinq cent mille manifestants
500000 j'imagine pour nous tous les
dirigeants étaient là pour le pc torres
duclos pour les radicaux daladier et les
droites comme d'habitude brasillach
parle de cortège expiatoire morath de
gibier de bagnes de paix gramitech de
vie des faubourgs tu veux rentrer
vraiment aux libyens de plessis
catherine va mieux la douleur physique
n'est rien intéresse le pire c'est ce
cauchemar qui revient cette violence
d'ouvriers au nez quand je te disais de
prendre des gardes du corps je peux pas
dire comme ça la vie s'éteint pas craint
de la perte de maxime
il fait frais rentres tu reçois des
centaines de lettres écoute celle-ci
haute loire scheer léon blum nous sommes
scandalisés par la vente à nous vous
souhaitons bon rétablissement nous vous
embrassons janata dal 14 16 ans des
gamines 230 cheminots d'austerlitz ou
est rapide rétablissement aux camarades
blum y en a des centaines cancer annonce
e3 automne l hypocrite
depuis des années c'est le même
enthousiasme à chaque réunion ils se
précipitent pour te parler de touche et
de serrer la main en tube plongeur
écoute 2300 mineurs de liévin scandalisé
par l'attentât souhaite bonne santé à
léon blum 800 prolétaires de chez
renault adresses au chef du front
populaire sentiment de fraternité
on est tout près du culte de la
personnalité
de quoi tester à ce que j'ai dit l'autre
jour à lambert est beau je suis trop
vieux maintenant pour me lancer dans de
nouveaux combats
je n'ai jamais bien de vieux se rétablir
aussi vite après un tel choc
si tu aimes tu tout donné au parti j'ai
bien le droit de vivre un peu avec toi
selon mme eliane mes livres et de mes
amis
tu comprends les rangs mais si tu
renonces les fascistes auront gagné par
vote dans deux mois qui peut diriger la
campagne jaurès les ne jamais lâcher
jaurès oui ça c'est un argument mais ils
l'ont tué
je suis là on continue ensemble
n'est ce pas là tu vois
il était monté sur une table et quand il
commençait à parler personne n'attendait
personne ne comprenait alors il ya eu un
murmures dans la foule et il a élevé la
voix de plus en plus fort oui mes amis
mes camarades au kebab et 1 td dans
l'épreuve
je vous le dis ici à narbonne où je me
sens chez moi en ce 21 avril
vous tenez entre vos mains le bel idéal
socialiste mettre la machine au service
de l'homme
réduire la durée du travail bien
répartir les richesses est allé sur
l'humanité les bienfaits collective de
la nature et du progrès pas une voix ne
montre contre le fascisme pour la paix
pour la paix et pour la liberté
c'était étonnant de voir se pérenniser
au milieu des vignes puis j'ai
l'impression que cette campagne en bête
et puis narbonne c'est le bout du monde
vous le connaissez bien non pas vraiment
je fais juste vu une fois pour ma part
d'un café ah non moi je peux pas le
travail m'attend juste un petit café je
travaille 50 heures par semaine -
monsieur 50 heures 50 heures c'était non
ben oui c'est énorme au bon marché c'est
50 heures par semaine mais attends un
peu les élections davy crockett suis sûr
que ça peut changer
nous pouvons d'ores et déjà pronostiqué
que tout se jouera au 2e tour
à droite les modérés sont laminés on va
gagner moins de 2% sur 1932 c'est
désolant
décidément cette france paysanne
limbourgeoise est indécrottable
pour tous même les résultats définitifs
et même si personne ne croit à la
recette miracle
pas même les prolétaires ces chiffres
disent autre chose
on stagne on verra déco s'effondre par
contre le péché gagne 700 mille voix
notre parti est trop timoré la pop le
funk gauche plus combative le peuple pas
tout le peuple chérir et puis d'avoir
des communistes va effrayer les modérer
au second tour bon j'ai créé mon
éditorial il faut que je sois prudent et
en même temps je dois les galvaniser
nous même si vous pouviez le forcer au
populaire je pourrai dormir on se
retrouve mardi à narbonne
j'ai autant envie d'y aller que de me
faire lâcher mais bon quand on pense que
que les radicaux là-bas distribuer des
tracts contre moi avec tous les
antisémites du coin quel pays enfin j'y
serai jusqu'à dimanche
attendons le soir du deuxième tour
on verra bien centré sur
accompagné le à narbonne ça lui fera
plaisir
je semble de nouveau
notre camarade géo lagrange est élu dans
le nord
on juste à l'ombre aussi
m
[Musique]
377 de
avant
aucun
le camarade jacques ducrocq des murs pas
libre
[Applaudissements]
c'est le 378e et le du front populaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné oui oui très bien
quelle histoire on a gagné on doit
revendre et quel gouvernement
pourquoi je ne vais pas dire je les
résultats sont clairs le gouvernement
doit être dirigée par un socialiste
c'est bien ton avis oui qui sinon toi
peut diriger ce gouvernement
beaucoup d'autres thérèse tu n'imagines
pas tout à coup le nombre de prétendants
toute façon c'est le président de la
république qui décide c'est la
constitution les ans je sais mais le
brun n'a pas le choix c'est toi qui le
dit oui et le parti elle dira aussi tu
ne vas quand même pas tu abrité derrière
scène paderne de lebrun pour te dérobés
allez on tu m'entends materne badiane
c'est tout de même le président de la
république
dure journée intéresse bien dans miracle
le président du conseil
peut-être serait-il bon d'abréger la
transition entre votre gouvernement et
la nouvelle majorité de lyon blot la
constitution dit que la chambre doit
aller au terme de la législature
c'est le 4 juin cela nous laisse un mois
le président lebrun a été clair un mois
c'est un mois cheikh sarr hop mais je
sens une tension dans le pays
arrêtez de pleurnicher lambert riboud la
république en a vu d'autres le pays
digérera le front populaire comme l'
affaire dreyfus ou ou l'assassinât de
jaurès le temps mon ami le temps blum
n'est pas un révolutionnaire
vous le connaissez bien
ce n'est pas un agité mais bien ce foutu
programme du front populaire
jusqu'où ira-t-il si le pc demande plus
en émoi vous devez accélérer la
transition
non le président de la république veut
que je reste
alors je reste et puis entre les
promesses électorales et la direction du
gouvernement il y à la réalité
on verra si blum tient ses engagements
château pape-clément 1924 décidément
vous savez le sens de l'humour et de
l'histoire
la gauche avait gagné déjà et en 18 mois
elle était au tapis et rien n'avait
changé et nous sommes toujours là en
train de déguster la france éternelle un
grand bordeaux qui traverse les âges
comme loup la chambre doit aller au
terme de la législature
nous avons un mois
à moi c'est trop long les ouvriers ont
les yeux braqués sur nous brusquer les
choses
je ne provoquera pas la démission de
sarrau je ne me prends clamerait pas
chef du gouvernement je respecterai la
loire isère
mais pourquoi respecter un ordre qui
n'est pas le nôtre sortir de la légalité
c'est ouvrir la porte à l'aventuré je ne
fournira aucun prétexte à nos
adversaires
n'oubliez pas les ligues fascistes
justement il faut bouger plus vite que
croyez vous qu'un autre place que les
fascistes et i try facilement pu faire
nous ne sommes pas des fascistes
monsieur blum oui excusez moi
[Musique]
arrivé chez nous elle est tombée de sa
chaise en syncope disait léon elle est
surmené
et puis a toujours peur pour toi
alors docteur le coût est bon de coeur
aussi mais est un peu faible mais vous
pouvez la voir monsieur le président et
ce malaise qu'est ce que c'est ne savons
pas encore la dernière fois j'ai voulu
la garder mais elle a refusé la dernière
fois votre femme est venue me voir en
janvier puis à nouveau en mars avec
toujours des fièvres et surtout cette
fatigue qui la mine
c'est là que j'ai voulu l'hospitaliser
pour des examens complets pourquoi
n'avez vous rien dit elle nous avait
juré de ne pas vous en parler avant les
examens informez moi avant de leur
parler
merci docteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce sera notre france cet enthousiasme
des masses il serait périlleux et
tragique de ne décevoir mais si nous
restons unis si nous savons être à la
fois sage et audacieux alors nous
remporterons la victoire victoire de la
liberté contre le fascisme de la justice
sociale et de l'antre l'iniquité et le
désordre
et cette victoire c'est à moi de vous y
conduire je serai votre chef
et tant pis si je n'avais pas envie de
l'être je le suis
l'histoire en a décidé ainsi
alors on peut louer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sera
c'est pourquoi y'a qu'à trois mois n'y
aurait tout abandonner on y vient dé
vous démentez pour prendre
[Applaudissements]
ça va
il m'a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour torres bonjour merci d'être là
pour tout vous dire j'ai horreur des
salles enfumées et des palabres sans fin
j'ai lu votre communiqué votre décision
de ne pas participer au gouvernement
c'est une erreur on s'est battus
ensemble on a gagné ensemble neutrons
gouverner ensemble
c'est un point de vue que je comprends
alors c'est embarrassant de dire oui
après avoir dit non mais il ya la menace
fasciste
on serre les rangs ouvriers c'est simple
plus simple à dire qu'à faire mais si
thorez d'un gouvernement commun
un comité de salut public vous m'avez
mal compris
j'ai plaidé pour l'entrée du parti au
gouvernement la majorité du comité
central ne veut pas mes camarades
soviétique non plus nous soutiendrons
sans participer
merci de votre franchise nous verrons
régulièrement je vous tiendrai informé
avoir torres
les médecins m'ont rassuré c'est
seulement une grande fatigue
il te faut du repos tu les mets dans
l'eau et quand une bande d'un vide dans
leur maison tu te reposes en biolab
accaparé la question et je sort demain
et au phare je ne te quitte pas d'une
semelle sur tes pensées soient
raisonnables je connais les médecins
continuent vaille et envoie la campagne
le grand air c'est le remède miracle
tu rejoindre pau est ce que je t'ai
laissé à l'hôpital mois
quelle tête de mule dans ce cas passons
au moins le week-end chez eux
tu rejoindras dimanche aussi j'ai besoin
de souffler alors ton discours au comité
national
je suis interrogé sur mes capacités mais
aptitudes
j'ai dit aux camarades qu'il fallait
peut-être qu'à la tête du gouvernement
dit un autre homme qui se révèle couche
de terre
je n'étais pas convaincu d'avoir des
qualités d'un chef que ce serait une
épreuve pour moi
certains ont été choqués si toi tu es
doute comment de tuque les camarades se
mobilisent
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent que je jure que
je me transforme en doute chez en fureur
un petit père des peuples
je veux l'adhésion des masses mais pas
une adhésion aveugle des slogans
simplistes
parfois les camarades ont besoin de
certitudes clients au congrès temps
forts disait déjà que le peuple ne doit
pas est un troupeau qu'on mène à la
baguette qui doit être sensible aux
appels de la raison du coeur donc doute
sensible aux doutes thérèse ya que les
animaux qui ne doute pas réduire l'homme
à ce statut c'est ce que font hitler
mussolini staline
c'est indigne de nous si juste
j'ai complètement d'accord avec toi
vivement demain que sortie c'est
[Musique]
bon
je voulais pas venir ça m'impressionne
quoi un ces immeubles
je me sens pas à l'aise dans ce quartier
c'est bizarre quand même un intellectuel
épouser la cause du peuple mais on se
méfie mais on devrait pas de raison mais
ça fait quand même drôle réaction m'aide
à comprendre le succès des attaques de
maurras contre nous la soif de lourches
bien
tu parlais avec les camarades
ça va plus thérèse on respecte la
constitution mais pendant ce temps là le
patronat se durcit et nous reste les
bras ballants on attend on attend
je sais les eaux en est conscient mais
il est convaincu qu'on ne peut agir
autrement
même chez nous au bon marché les filles
commencent à s'inquiéter
il répète qu'il fera voter les lois
sociales en juin pour lui ça peut
attendre trois semaines annie ainsi tout
d'où vient la réunion ce soir j'y
arriverai peut-être en retard je j
médecin un bon ça va pas mieux poursuit
mais c'est pour rassurer lyon sinon ils
menacent de tout laisser tomber
tu imagines communiqué de monsieur blum
la fatigue de ma femme oblige à renoncer
à la politique
alors des camarades s'impatiente
c'était tendu à la section non je te
parle de 7
ces examens tout va bien les eaux je
n'ai rien suis en pleine forme un ça va
et toi rien de mauvaises nouvelles
raconte non je n'en parlerai demain
maintenant s'il te plaît un attentat
fasciste d'un quartier juif quatre
blessés je suis allé ils ont dit à tous
ses devoirs non très touché ils m'ont
dit qu'il fallait surtout pas que je
gouverne le pays sinon les fascistes
déchaînant contre la communauté juive
syrienne image in bloom expliquant à
lévis que bloom a bien le droit de
diriger le pays comme un catholique où
comme à porter sans un sens et c'est
tout non c'est pas tout bloc de
courbevoie se mettent en grève tu sais
les avions vous voyez occupent les
usines de licenciement pour fait de
grève le 1er mai at aurait pu dire lévy
que le juif bloc se conduit comme
n'importe quel autre patron c'est
agaçant ces grèves qui se multiplient
prague et wav latécoère a toulouse je
craint la contagion
moi je la souhaite
n'y aurait rien de pire thérèse rien de
pire pour durer pour durer longtemps
il faudra donner très vite le sentiment
de la réussite c'est une épreuve que
vous ferez sur moi et que je ferais sur
moi même mais il y a quelque chose qui
ne nous manquera jamais c'est la
résolution c'est le courage et c'est la
fidélité
je ne me présente pas à vous aujourd'hui
comme un homme déjà accablé davance le
poids des charges et des responsabilités
qui la table je ne viens pas ici en
disant au t2 moi ce qu'à nice
je n'ai pas voulu cela je n'ai pas
demandé cela si si
voulu cela parce que cela c'est la
victoire de notre parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu avais raison ce séjour chez les
grands une boum m'a fait du bien
conduit moins vite
tu sais combien a coûté tant dernier
accrochage non 7200 francs 7200 francs
comment va-t-on faire les ans le toque
et de poche peut encore payé 7200 francs
avant excuse moi
bon on va les laisser passer
tu t'en vas
je vais cueillir des aubépines
[Musique]
tu es soucieux
je réfléchis à quoi au pouvoir un accès
de narcissisme
je n'ai jamais recherché le pouvoir
c'est un euphémisme je me suis même
donné plus de mal à m'en écarter que
d'autres s'en approcher j'en ai même
écarté le parti aussi longtemps possible
et bien continuer là le président de la
république ne veut pas de toi laisse le
gouvernement aux radicaux
écoute moi à thérèse j'ai dit aussi
longtemps que possible
le moment est venu mais franchement
j'aurais pu rêver meilleure situation
parce que tu penses et accéder au
pouvoir dans des conditions idéales
tu te vois disant aux électeurs qui ont
voté pour toi je m'en lave les mains je
rentre à la maison et j'ai écrit une
suite à mon essai sur le mariage pour
dénoncer l'existence insupportable que
thérèse ma pause absurde non pourquoi
faut-il que je dirige pis si tout allait
bien ce bon vieux pays aurait encore
voter à droite c'est dans les moments
difficiles qu'ils tournent un gaucher
[Musique]
je gouvernerai caresse je te dirais
comme ce vieux militant que j'ai
rencontrés hier enfin les difficultés
commencent c'est important qu'ils soient
là tu sais bien
raven en une minute au choix des hommes
pour les socialistes je me débrouillerai
je les connais pour les radicaux y aura
besoin de vos suggestions
n'oubliez pas j'ai trois impératifs 1
je veux des femmes au gouvernement
quitte moi lesquels et pour quel poste
de jeu créé un ministère des sports et
des loisirs
ac il confié 3 je veux donner un élan
nouveau à la recherche scientifique me
faut un an
pensez-y nous en parlerons demain
tout seul un groupe je veux lui parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lâcher surtout pas on fait pas tient la
corde comme si le patron était au bout
[Musique]
j'avais grammont et par mer ont débrayé
on est des millions des millions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ça se passe un very bad
bonjour paul ils occupent nos usines
d'une nouveauté soutien qui dirige le
mouvement
c'est au moment des personnes je ne sais
pas d'où ça vient
et surtout je ne sais pas où on va enfin
bon tu parles papale blum qu'est ce
qu'il fait quand il forme son
gouvernement nilesat forme il consultait
boyd a tort tous les patrons disent la
même chose on va tout droit au bordel
excusez moi mais avec ces grèves ont
plomb drop est rappelé que proposent les
patrons c'est très simple que bloom
sortent du bois qu'ils calment le jeu
avant qu'il soit trop tard
sinon le pays sombre dans l'anarchie
alors vous les connaissez avec moi et
événements et bien présent rien pendant
dix jours c'est beaucoup trop long il
faut que bloom prennent le pouvoir
sinon le pays risque la fiq si je
transmettrai compter sur moi
[Musique]
à
ce film a été tourné hier
juste impressionnant
c'est que vous voudrions je peux
organiser d'autres projections
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est devant hispano suiza ils sont
vraiment bien marcel au bon marché ça
bouge pas tu vois quand je parle de
débrayer les filets réagissent pas
j'avais déjà fait la grève dans les
grands magasins
jamais
[Musique]
bloom est catégorique jours ci la
cgt-energie banques contrôlent plus rien
il faut arrêter sa vie arrêtez vu tu
plaisantes toutes les corporations entre
dans la danse c'est du jamais vu
franchement qui pousse pas un peu à la
roue il faut le répéter combien de fois
jules on est dépassé on est dépassé
c'est un mouvement unique c'est une
grève générale c'est comme on l'aurait
voulu à 14 pour éviter la guerre
sauf que là il demandait rien à personne
esi vont aller aux jo oui merci camarade
de nemo cours c'était la métallurgie
la plupart nos délégués sont fait virer
résultat c'est le bordel et les grands
magasins
tu as vu les grands magasins y a pas de
syndicat y'a pas de syndiqués et c'est
des femmes belges occupent depuis ce
matin elle occupe diable on que c'est
plus simple et plus inquiétant qu'un
complot pendant qu'il prend son temps
pour former le gouvernement
le pr neta ria à lui pensé garantie
camarades se moquent
voilà la vérité
il faut que je le vois j'arrive la
banlieue c'est impressionnant monsieur
bouchard en temps normal il n'aime pas
beaucoup répondre aux questions mais là
j'ai peur qu'il vous envoie sur les
roses
comment voulez vous j'ai écrit mon livre
si je passe à côté de sa maman l'a bien
attendu mais je vous aurais prévenu
vous avez lu l'article de marceau pivert
tout est possible vous y croyez qu'on
peut tout changer
j'imagine mal et on blum en train
d'appuyer une révolution entre
révolution et l'inaction il ya une marge
vous trouvez votre mari inactifs ou pas
du tout je suis attentive à ce que les
grèves nous disent qu'est ce qu'elles
disent d'après vous que les souffrances
les amertumes accumulées pendant des
décennies éclater les ouvriers réclament
leur dû ils ne veulent plus attendre
et qu'en pensent les robes longues nuits
posez lui la question merci bouge ça va
pas excusez moi vous pouvez revenir un
autre show oui désolé j'avais dit la
banque ma famille cela nous composons
cours il n'ose pas mais tu vois personne
si mon père voyez ça
enfin c'est pareil saint-etienne
marseille lyon lille tout la métallurgie
a les bras croisés je fais d'autres
bâtiments tous les grands chantiers sont
occupés tous la secrétaire a fait une
synthèse des revendications alors matin
10 à 15% d'augmentation de salaire
congés payés 8 à 15 jours reconnaissance
des syndicats convention collective par
branches élections de délégués du
personnel réintégration de des militants
syndicaux licenciés
j'en passe ils sont malades il faut
diriger du gouvernement l'évacuation par
la force
à donges un cas possible pas la police
pas l'armé non miscibles m'accepter tu
te rends compte qu'ils arriveraient des
moitiés du sort ce serait la révolution
sont rejaillirait sur nous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors j'ai vu des une bonne
approche de bloom est alors alors alors
il faut négocier avec la cgt
six jours arrivent à contrôler le
mouvement négocier dans ces conditions
si pour nous la mort assurée écoutez
monsieur si l'un d'entre vous veulent ma
plage de lui celle avec plaisir
tu a bonne mine
que mieux qu'hier ouais ça va jaser que
ton dernier discours ces difficultés
heureuse espérer bienvenus eh bien nous
essaierons de les résoudre par l'action
en mettant très vite la classe ouvrière
en face de résultats
j'exagère comme si ces greffes donné
tant de plaisir mais je ne parlais pas
des grèves alors ces greffes gens
pensent quoi m'ennuie je les prends
comme une gifle
oui les capitaux dont j'ai besoin vont
fuir à l'étranger et patrons sont
tétanisés les petits bourgeois sa folle
quand on possède est complètement
déstabilisée non c'est grève se renforce
la peur rendra les patrons plus souple
supporter cet avis pardonne moi les
grévistes sont tes meilleurs alliés les
ans j'étais connu plus clairvoyants sais
que je vais y terese oui
tu as oublié le président des radicaux
de là dessus
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait les on est
bien gouvernement non je parle de la
grève générale qu'est ce qu'on fait et
urgences je connais le calendrier
j'agirai après mon investiture dans la
légalité
certes certains meilleure attitude c'est
le calme
parlons du gouvernement tu veux des
femmes
oui ça dispensable on n'a pas assez de
problèmes comme ça et tu vas me demander
de leur donner le droit de vote non du
sénat refuserait pas moi aussi je te le
dis tout net moi aussi ça n'a pas été
facile mais j'ai convaincu mes amis tout
accord pour deux femmes ministres
non je veux 3 tu veux deux femmes deux
socialistes bien sûr perche
il faut que je tienne quelque chose en
échange
une troisième ministre mais une radicale
et ce sera à n'importe qui charles yvon
pas n'importe qui madame braille fait la
femme du philosophe une personnalité
exceptionnelle pour une femme très bon
choix
je t'en conjure arrête c'est vraiment ce
qui me catastrophe un voile et coco et
que ça s'arrête on sent que ça s'arrête
je crois le bras jeudi le gouvernement
est presque au complet
je réfléchis seulement sur trois ou
quatre postes notamment le secrétariat
d'état aux sports et loisirs nous avons
pensé à léo lagrange
maintenant j'aurais préféré un homme
plus proche de moi je le trouve un peu
jeune emporté c'est un très bon avocat
vous savez on me fait penser à jaurès et
je me dis ah là physiquement
bon je l'appellerai prévenait alors les
greffes qui commence
un véritable raz-de-marée plus de 12000
usines occupées
on risque la paralysie totale encore
huit jours et ce sera le rationnement ou
la réquisition
oui j'ai vu jouer hier soir pour le
sonder pour savoir ce qu'il propose je
vous avais pourtant rapporté notre
entrevue
je sais mais je vous laisse juger par
moi même je vaux m'agace je sais que
c'est réciproque
il affirme que la cgt ne contrôle pas
tous nos camarades le confirmer j'ai eu
le tenez vous informé auprès des
syndicats paul auprès du patronat et
vous andré prenez la température des
groupes parlementaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je suis pressé cécile est
passé par thérèse ce matin oui je suis
inquiet hier il était livide elle
tremblait de fièvre ça recommence je n'y
comprends rien
j'ai appelé le professeur austère c'est
le meilleur qui la verra demain il faut
qu'il a guéri quand je la bois dans ce
nid toute tremblante avec ce sourire qui
se veut rassurant c'est un cauchemar
comment a assuré matignon est on si vous
voulez qu'elle se batte battez vous
aussi je vous en prie
[Musique]
ne craignez rien à ces sites
je me parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de vivre
je vais
le gouvernement est au complet monsieur
le président du temps j'ai respecté la
constitution
prenez vous aller vite maintenant
j'ai prévenu sa roue il est prêt à
passer sur les pouvoirs peut avoir lieu
dès ce soir en collision à 18h ce soir
déjà
oui pour les ministères de l'intérieur
et du travail
l'urgence ce sont les grèves monsieur le
président du conseil ce soir c'est
possible quand ils rêvent ou devant lui
chambre pour l'investiture samedi
t'nb c'est trop long la situation nous
échappe
ils n'ont pas ce qui se passe dans le
pays il faudrait être aveugle monsieur
président eh bien alors agissez c'est ce
que je fais et je n'irais pas plus vite
puisqu'il en est ainsi
monsieur blum je vous en conjure
je vous en prie dès demain montant dès
demain adressez vous aux ouvriers par la
radio ils ont confiance en vous êtes
socialiste il veut croire en moi
j'espère
c'est une idée monsieur le président
c'est une idée
je suis président président du conseil
moi j'en sais yes je vous en prie voici
en direct de notre studio
l'allocution de monsieur léon blum
président du conseil mes chers
compatriotes le gouvernement ne manquera
aucun des engagements qu'il a pris
envers vous mais sa force réside avant
tout dans la confiance du peuple
l'action du gouvernement pour être
efficace doit s'exercer dans l'ordre
toute panique toute confusion
serviraient les desseins obscurs des
adversaires du front populaire dont
certains préparent déjà leur revanche le
gouvernement devant tant que travailleur
de s'en remettre à la loi pour celle de
leurs revendications qui doivent être
réglés par la loi pour suivre les autres
dans le car la dignité et la discipline
il demande au patronat d'examiner ses
revendications dans un large esprit
d'équité
il déplorait qu'une tactique patronale
d'intransigeance paraît coïncidé avec
son arrivée au pouvoir demandent enfin
la victoire du 26 avril et du 3 mai
reçoit aujourd'hui sa pleine
consécration un grand avenir s'ouvre
devant la démocratie française
je le jure comme un chef du gouvernement
de s'y engager avec une force tranquille
qui est la garantie des victoires
nouvelle
elle dort nom jules vous avez vu les
syndicats mission accomplie mais pas son
mal
j'ai obtenu du carburant de la farine il
y aura du pain mais on ne tiendra pas
longtemps les gens votre discours n'a
pas suffi la grève continue et même elle
s'est encore et toi paul j'ai vu lambert
ribot le patronat est prêt à céder il et
implore bien c'est salengro kir avoir
joui muniz l'intérieur et membre de la
cgt ça devrait nous aider ils
prépareront la négociation il faudrait
que les discussions aient lieu à
matignon
tulle et préciserait je vais penser je
met la dernière main à ma déclaration
puis j'irai dormir a pas un seul mes
amis tout va bien paul si tu peux faire
entrer l'ambassadeur d'espagne
il ya une heure qui m'attend au revoir
alain giresse
si on avait dit qu'un jour comme
celui-là je résisterai ta cravate je
ferai comme toi le jour tu seras premier
ministre c'est pas demain la veille
qu'une femme sera président du conseil
est bon parfait bon pour le service je
ne quitterai pas tessier
messieurs dès la semaine prochaine
le gouvernement déposera des projets de
loi qui donneront vie au programme du
front populaire concerneront la semaine
de 40 heures les conventions collectives
dans les entreprises les congés payés de
15 jours pour les salariés
les nationalisations et les grands
travaux au canada ça serait une
révolution
sitôt ces mesures votées nous
présenterons parlement une seconde série
de projets visant notamment le fonds
national de chômage l'assurance contre
les calamités agricoles
l'aménagement des dettes agricole
un régime de retraite garanti 100 contre
la misère les vieux travailleurs des
villes et des campagnes
hélène vous saisiront ensuite dans l'art
système de simplification et de détente
fiscale soulageant la production et le
commerce ne demandant de nouvelles
ressources qu'à la contribution de la
richesse acquise à la répression de la
fraude et surtout à la reprise de
l'activité générale
tandis que nous nous efforcerons ainsi
de ranimer l'économie française de
résorber le chômage d'accroître la masse
des revenus consommables de fournir un
peu de bien-être et de sécurité à tous
ceux qui créent par leur travail la
véritable richesse nous en rose à
gouverner le pays
nous assurerons l'homme républicain et
si des institutions démocratiques
étaient attaqués nous en assurerons le
respect est inviolable avec vigueur la
fidélité à nos engagements
tel sera notre règle le bien public
tel sera notre put
[Applaudissements]
la france est un pays extraordinaire
je m'attendais à un débat politique j'ai
entendu la droite polémique et pendant
deux heures contre les juifs
la république la laïcité quand les
québécois vont lire mon livre une croix
en temps il n'ya pas d'antisémitisme
chez vous monsieur bouchard moi ça peut
se fout ce fanatique là les fascistes
vallat xavier vallat monsieur bouchard
vous êtes parmi nous ce soir
félicitations à ce président c'est moi
qui ai demandé intéresse de l'invité
alors soyez le bienvenu
je suis prêt si on passe à table je suis
désolé d'être indiscret et pourquoi leur
as tu dis que les occupations d'usinés
était illégal mais parce que c'est la
vérité
elles sont politiquement c'était pas
très habile la morale en politique
existe aucune contradiction entre la
vérité est là que j les clients le
moraliste n'est jamais bien loin
mais site illégal il faut agir
mais pourquoi pas vous allez envoyer la
troupe dans les usines
il ya eu des précédents c'est pas
possible rassurez vous ça ne m'est
jamais venu à l'esprit mais je vois avec
un étonnement douloureux que dans mon
propre parti je passe pour un social
traître
merci de votre confiance
[Musique]
je
sur ce paragraphe est difficilement
acceptable mais il faut l'accepter
messieurs
[Musique]
messieurs vous aurez bientôt pour
signature
le protocole consignant les accords que
vous avez conclu
ainsi pourra s'achever dans le calme le
plus formidable conflit social qui est
connu la république
je forme le voeu que ces accords
matignon inauguré une ère où dans le
respect mutuel syndicats ouvriers et
patronaux règles l'inévitable conflit
par la négociation et le compromis qui
sont l'une et l'autre les vertus
irremplaçable de la démocratie et de la
république
merci tout net je suis comme toi les
eaux à modéré mais je connais bien mes
patrons tu seras contre 3 dès que le
vent va tourner un à blaise de l'homme
c'est l'espérance
j'espère que ce sera dur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les peaux de monsieur larose coin
qu'est ce que je disais déjà ah oui les
congés payés ils sont votés il ne reste
messieurs a donné aux ouvriers les
moyens de voyager bien monsieur le
ministre
oui mais c'est trop cher nous allons
créer ensemble des billets de congé à
prix réduit a ressemble au ministère va
éditer des formulaires ils seront la
disposition des employés on y mettra le
nombre de jours de congés et date la
destination le nombre de personnes et
l'ouvrier son patron l'écho signeront je
ne comprends pas bien monsieur le
ministre
à la vue de ce billet vous délivrera un
titre de transport avec une réduction
2011 50 % le monsieur lagrange
monsieur le ministre pardon monsieur le
ministre c'est impossible c'est anti
ferroviaire anti ferroviaire messieurs
n'oubliez pas que c'est l'état qui vous
donne les concessions estimez vous
heureux de ne pas être nationalisées
monsieur le ministre s'il vous plaît 30%
pas plus
je veux 50% vous proposez 30 ce sera de
40% et un bon compromis d'accord allez
vous empocherez comment on va les
locomotives
vous verrez messieurs le tourisme
populaire c'est ferroviaire voulez vous
dire quelque chose pour le conte prépare
notre accord à laugnac s'il vous plaît 2
je vais faire encadrer ce numéro jamais
je n'aurais pu imaginer ça il ya trois
mois quand j'ai payé fauté à l'unanimité
congés payés 500 sont trois voix pour
une contre convention collective 563
pour 5 contre la semaine de 40 heures 45
et plus difficile 1 mais voter ce sera
ma fierté d'avoir modifié la vie du
peuple à lui zine et or de lusine gta
rêve maintenant c'est une réalité
[Applaudissements]
je pense à jaurès à ses trente années
donné au parti
quel chemin parcouru
oui c'est moi
les professeurs
ne te concernait d'estomac on la perd
demain matin
[Musique]
e
je ne suis pas sortie souvent de mon
hôtel matignon pendant la durée de mon
ministère
mais chaque fois que j'ai traversé la
grande banlieue parisienne les routes
couvertes de ces théories de tacots de
moto2 tandem avec des couples d'ouvriers
vêtu depuis le vert assorti même montré
que l'idée de loisirs réveiller chez eux
une espèce de coke est très naturel et
simple
[Musique]
cela donne le sentiment que par
l'organisation du travail et des loisirs
nous avons apporté une espèce d'embellie
d'éclaircies dans des vies difficiles et
obscur
[Musique]
jamais nous n'avons connu une période
aussi calme presque sereine comme si la
vie allait changer
c'est vrai l'espéranto d'un parfum
différent à l'air que l'on respire je ne
vous connaissez pas cette propension au
lyrisme
on me l'a souvent reproché à te
reprocher cela mais aussi l' inverse
en somme je ne suis jamais dans le temps
il faut reconnaître que vous aussi
souvent entre euphorie et pessimisme eh
bien je vais confirmé ce travers je ne
partage pas votre fort y la situation
sociale et meyer le prolétariat
retrouver sa dignité
mais les patrons relève la tête comme si
le bel été socialiste était fini je ne
ressens pas sa charge intéresse quand
elle disait que les grévistes étaient
meilleurs alliés en fallait on les lois
sont votées la classe ouvrière et agira
si les patrons restent contenues ou le
mur de l'argent à passer à pas sur ce
qui a soulevé les ouvriers en mai
n'existe plus nous n'avons plus rien à
donner
et bien quel tableau
et voilà donc aussi démunis non mais
nous dépendons de force que nous que
nous ne maîtrisons pas du communiste et
les radicaux
oui bien sûr leurs attaques contre notre
politique en espagne inquiètent et les
succès de franco n'arrangeront rien
l'espagne
quelques blessures
est-ce qu'il ya ici un seul un qui croit
que j'ai changé depuis trois mois je
vous assure que ces trois mois me
paraissent d'un mois en ce moment au
sinon je ne sais combien d'années un
panneau d'intervention kong et vous
quand je lis comme vous dans les
journaux le récit de la puisse dire où
l'agonie des derniers défenseurs est ce
que vous croyez que mon coeur n'est pas
déchiré
on ne croyait rien de tout cela n'est ce
pas
on avait gâché la soirée les en moi qui
voyait la vie en rose
l'accord des mois au moins le privilège
de l'âge la vie est rarement ross et
l'est j'ai déjà pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as manqué marcel
[Musique]
je t'ai écrit c'est à la poste espagnol
c'est compliqué
et puis j'ai beaucoup circulé devront à
l'autre est ce que les républicains
tiennent le coup franc qu'on progresse
partout j'ai bien peur que bloom se soit
trompé les thérèse elle va de plus en
plus mal comment il prend sur mulhouse
ben il vit un cauchemar ce serait le cas
pour n'importe qui mais vraiment ce
moment pour lui c'est pire que tout j'en
ai inséré ans je n'entendais plus à
l'hôpital elle marcherait l'hôpital tu
seras mieux soigner je t'en prie
intéresse c'est une démissionne pas
zilina
mais ça n'a rien à voir mon amour tu
veux te soigner pour le reste le reste
je veux dire quoi les pins
elle te plaît
eh ben
le reste ne reste tu sais bien
j'ai les dévaluations les grèves à
patronat qui sabotent nord qui file le
parti qui va chine a accepté la pause et
les radicaux qui me lâche qui elle est
majoritaire à l'assemblée n'est encore
qu'à lundi comme traille héros pourquoi
avec dix idées
j'appelle au peuple mobilisent
devant la rue ils céderont je ne veux
pas d'épreuve de force le pouvoir je
l'exercé dans la légalité
avec la confiance des chambres si je ne
l'est plus
je m'ennuierais
propre histoire
pose-toi je t'en prie
[Musique]
je suis de là
atterré devant les débris d'une oeuvre
rompu entre mes mains
thérèse n'est plus habilité 36 ses mots
c'est un moment où toute croyance redire
nous se sont perdus dans un monde à
jamais hostile
comme tous les hommes j'ai connu dans ma
vie un certain nombre d'heures semblable
à celle là ils existent pour moi
quelques maîtres mots qui en expriment
de désolation et qui me reviennent
mécaniquement à l'esprit je vois qu'un
écart des ans se creuse ainsi entre la
réalité et les constructions de penser
ou du rêve je suis vieux je ne toucherai
pas la terre promise
je ne verrai pas des peuples dans la
justice et dans la paix
tu ne verrait pas sinon l'image du poète
les nations assises autour de leur foyer
comme des ce retour de l'autre mais ce
que la noblesse de l'homme n'est pas
d'espérer de travailler à une oeuvre qui
ne contemplera pas achevé et dont il ne
profitera pas lui-même
[Musique]
où
non
[Musique]
ans